we start with a tragedy unfolding in the
UK police say 39 people have been found
dead in a truck container near London
the vehicle was found at the water glade
industrial park close to docks on the
River Thames the truck is believed to
have come from Bulgaria the driver has
been arrested on suspicion of murder
police say they are still trying to
identify the victims the vehicle is
thought to have entered the UK last
weekend and we can speak to our London
correspondent Charlotte apart she's
following this story for us and joins us
on the line
I shall echo what do we know so far
about the story so we're on our way to
the scene right now to get a better
picture of what happened there assuming
about what we know so far is that
emergency services were called to the
water Glade industrial park in a small
town in the county of Essex an hour east
of central London and that was shortly
before 1:40 a.m. last night following
this discovery of a lorry container with
people inside and sadly 39 people were
pronounced dead at the scene
police say that 38 of the bodies are
adults and one is a teenager and of
course at this point the inquiries are
still ongoing but authorities are in the
process of identifying the victims they
anticipate however that this could be a
quite a lengthy process and I think
what's important to note is that
authorities believe that the lorry is
from Bulgaria and entered the United
Kingdom at Holi had such a small town in
Wales and a major Irish seaport on
Saturday the 19th of October so four
days ago already and the driver a 25
year old man from Northern Ireland has
been arrested on the suspicion of murder
they have arrested him in connection
with this incident and he remains in
police custody they are inquiring of
course as to what has happened there and
of course I think the big question now
is whether those that were fire found
inside that truck were refugees
authorities have not confirmed that but
it does remind us of this horrific
incident in Austria in 2015 at the
height of the refugee crisis back then
in Europe where all the 70 people were
found
dead inside an abandoned shark all right
our correspondent shall atop what
speaking to us of him a near London
she's on her way to the scene there
thank you so much your Lata